another thing that we won't expect to
see much of during the postseason is
fans in stands if the cowboys had made
it there would have been 30 000
somehow at a t stadium elsewhere it's
going to be
for the most part fewer than 10 000 the
bills will have 6 700 the saints
will have 3 000 and only 3 000 that's
roughly the size of the crowd that we
saw
on friday night in the superdome when
ohio state beat clemson
here's sean payton coach of the saints
talking about
a plan that he kicked around
for filling up the superdome with a lot
more
than 3 000 people
you've got to be ready ready but i think
this year uniquely this year
look the away games for any of these
opponents is not as daunting maybe as it
would be when you have to go in and deal
with the crowd noise and all the other
factors
i brought up the idea of testing 50 000
people and quarantining them in a hotel
and having like the most safest
superdome
known to man scientifically bust them
they've tested every day
and you've got a covet free facility and
i think
i think that's possible i don't know if
it's taken off or not
yeah i was going to ask you how that
plan went over it can be done
but we focus on what we can control
after sean payton said that yesterday
plenty of the reporters who heard it
thought he was joking i can tell you
with 100 percent
certainty that was that joke he was not
joking right he was not joking
i knew i listen i knew about it
i knew about the planning i had heard
about the planning
as it was happening and it wasn't ripe
yet to be discussed and i wasn't
authorized to talk about it but i knew
i knew that they were at least trying
different ideas brainstorming different
ideas for getting
thousands of fans into the superdome
remember there was one point this season
chris where
reports started to surface and
statements started to be issued that the
saints were thinking about
playing at lsu state in baton rouge
right
because they would have had 25 000
people there this gets into the
specific politics between cities and
counties and
within states some jurisdictions let
them in
other jurisdictions no one gets in so i
think the nfl
and the saints particularly were trying
to come up with ways to maybe
find a path to getting people into the
superdome i don't think they ultimately
want to play any of their games at baton
rouge unless they absolutely have to
like you did back in 2005.
i did hurricane right but but but they
they wanted to get more people into the
superdome in a safe and appropriate way
and when you look around the league and
you see
over 10 000 fans in cleveland under
kansas city and over 30 000 fans in
dallas
and by all appearances and and who knows
if you can trust the claims and the
numbers and whatever because
who knows where people get covet 19. you
get it in so many different places
potentially
but when you look around and see so many
fans at other games it has to be
frustrating when you're a coach of an
nfl team saying why can't we work
something out here
to do it and sean payton tried it didn't
work right but he tried
tried and tried to do it the right way
too it wasn't like he just tried to do
it it was like oh the hell with it this
is what i want and i'll break all the
laws and rules and do it what you know
sure that's where i respect sean i also
respect sean because hey yes he's one of
the best head coaches we've seen in
football over the last 20 years
but he's always very aware of
the energy of his team trying to
motivate them give them the advantage
he understands how hard it is to go play
there with those fans
the energy it brings his team it's
daunting for the other team
but you know he he just i love him that
he just
exhausts all angles all the time he
really does whether it is going to
lsu and playing there which i did that
in 2005
i was the quarterback for the bucks it
wasn't that i i mean it
it's a weird experience i i don't know
how that would work out
but i appreciate sean payton that way
you know his motivational tactics every
wednesday what he does
all of those things uh he's he's just an
off all-in football guy all the time and
that's why i love him
i still worry about the saints suffering
the same fate that we have in 2017
2018 2019. it changes into that playoff
format that single elimination that
winner go home they've had their hearts
ripped out and
shown to them three different times
minneapolis miracle
the controversial non-call of pass
interference and then last year's
overtime game that ended in a
controversial non-call of offensive pass
interference
it really didn't become as big of a
thing as it could have been or should
have been
right i think also because another game
was starting right away and it was a
lower level it wasn't for a birth in the
super bowl but but hey i love kyle
rudolph but he pushed off he pushed off
and nobody said boo about it so the
saints
and how do you that's the real challenge
how do you get your guys
to not have that mindset i know of
it's gonna get us the snake's gonna bite
us in the butt
at some point we just don't know when we
don't know how
we don't know at which level but at some
point in the next three games
something's gonna happen to keep us from
getting to the super well
i mean that that goes into everything
you know we're just talking about that's
where sean you know sean payton's
amazing
you know yes i know this is like the
playoffs and what's he going to do here
and they've had their issues
but how does he get them to answer the
ball year after year after year like
he's done anyways with those crushing
losses
how does he get the team he's an
unbelievable people skills motivation
push the right buttons type of guy and
he just understands how to do that you
know even a good example
again was how coy he was about the
quarterback issue and all that
he's always looking for a way to give
his team an advantage there
i'm sure he did something this week mike
i'm sure
to change the vibe or get him to think
of something or showed him a
you know an ex-sports legend who might
have lost two or three crushing
losses and then came back to dominate
the world and things like that
that that he'll do something like that
to try to get him like hey
we're not the first team or sports
player to you know
be knocked on the ground a few times you
know but let's
let's be like some of these greats
whether it's muhammad ali or whatever
that's where he's amazing he just finds
ways to motivate his players and put a
positive vibe and thought in their head
i think the challenge for something like
this is how far do you go in pointing it
out
how much of you yeah right don't want to
make it too big
if you if you make it too big of a thing
that makes that nagging feeling bigger
than maybe it would have been
because no matter what they do on the
surface there's still going to be that
nagging feeling
that here it comes here it comes
here it comes and that's the challenge
psychologically and it's going to be
there
wild card division around nfc
championship
if they keep winning that sense in any
of those games
at a critical moment the boom is going
to be lowered on the saints and bust
goes their super bowl run
so look only two teams are going to make
it so chances are
right out of 14 teams for 12 of them
they're going to lose and some of them
may lose in a way that they regard as
spectacular
and horribly deflating but it is a
testament to sean payton
that he keeps them coming back for more
they keep having special seasons right
and getting back in position
to play in these games so whatever that
vibe is
from week one through week 17 chris that
gets them to
to move on that needs to carry over into
the postseason yeah
yeah i mean you know this week it maybe
is bigger than just hey
winning on the field we know that but
maybe if they get a win
you know that's the kind of thing too
that kind of washes the bad memories out
of your
you know your brain that way hey the
last two times they've been on the field
in playoff games yeah
they've kind of gotten screwed over
there's no there's no doubt you could
certainly make that
that case you know last year i do think
the defender
initially started contact on me on
rudolph and then rudolph pushed off
that's the only thing where i don't find
it as egregious as the year before and
all that
but you know still you know the fact
that
they continue to answer the bell and do
those things and now
maybe if they can get to the playoffs
get a win and get the vibes going
you know maybe that'll go a long way to
giving them confidence and making a run
here in the past i do think we're all
a little bit you know swiping the
the the saints under the rug a little
bit in the super bowl conversation i do
i think they're a super bowl football
team there's no doubt about that
but i don't think they're quite getting
the attention they deserve because of
those last two
postseason losses and we're not sure if
they can make it through
they need to win one yeah that's what i
mean similar to the way they've lost
maybe that's the key it's not just win
right it's have one of these crazy
moments at the end of the game go you're
go their way that's the way to exercise
that demon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports